this is going to look weird
because it points out
i know no no we don't lose it at all
he's so defused i'm here today with sam
grosski who's going to tell us how we
made barkovs how do we do it sam uh
watch my video presentation
what's up welcome to the behind the
scenes for bar cops a lot of you guys
were wondering hey you guys are using
that dog again rocky and we're like yeah
we are using again you know why it's
because he's an awesome dog actor you
may have seen him in his uh previous
video titled rocky his name
um but basically yeah he's an awesome
actor dog and we're like hey why not
make an attack dogs video with rocky so
what makes an awesome actor for a dog a
dog that looks very wanted to look so
it's like his tension's there
that is the tension is there and it's
like
you are the best actor
good job doc tension here dents in there
good yeah
basically over the course of two days uh
we shot the piece in the back alleyway
of our building where you guys have
probably seen it in numerous other
videos hey look it's minnie rocky
oh my god all right check this out we
built the shrink ray everybody you have
found out the secret it's a wild rock
captured in the pokeball yeah i'm gonna
capture the wild rocky out of pokeball
normally we don't really record outside
um but it's late and
you know our place is loud there's a lot
of people working and watching movies in
there so the video takes place in south
africa and basically
i'm trying to free all these miners
um and you guys are trying to
make them your slaves we want to make
them our slaves i know and that's what
i'm trying to keep you guys from doing
because that's the right thing to do now
who gave you the orders
uh top brass top brass top rafts give me
the orders can't tell me who nope it's
top secret this is uh this is our first
time using the mantis uh camera rig from
reality technica um
from what i hear it's the best big on
the market we're gonna find that out
today um this is the first time
of me getting a shot with this camera on
a shoulder mount ever so history is
being made right now
with the mantis
it's pretty hot
it's the hottest summer on record it's
pretty hot today's not that day though
it's still probably about 100 degrees
out no
anybody want to want to go find a
thermometer weatherman
it's 100 degrees outside
i've killed so many people over this
battle that i have i can't remember how
many hit are left
there you gotta do it just like that so
i put in my movie
the last thing you want to do in a video
called bar cops is be funny yes
okay i'm just i'm just gonna go for
something okay
i think that's five more down don't you
think i've earned it by now
your watch are you rolling i'll roll now
go for it
oh listen i'm killing him by the
busloads i can't keep count anymore
oh you can't keep count anymore
you can't i can't keep count
of the bus loads let me use the backup
come on throw me a bone here
you know it's too bad we weren't able to
shoot everything in one day if you're
doing a lot of these videos i hate
stressing out and trying to do a video
as fast as i can much rather take my
time shooting it because
a video is not all about post-production
the actual production matters quite a
bit
and if you can have a quality video if
you really take your time with the shots
and have good shots and you have
it applies good lighting and good
blocking and just
all around just a really well shot video
it goes a really long ways to making a
uh
a quality piece that people want to
watch
yeah uh definitely got some cool shots
today some really sweet action sequences
in the beginning uh
something was bogging us down during the
middle day i'm not sure what i think it
was maybe just the combination of the
really complicated setups and also just
the insane heat we had but you know we
got some cool stuff really happy to edit
it and you know we got another day of
shooting ahead of us hey guys what's up
it's day two uh we've re-ridden the
second half of the piece a little bit to
make it a little bit tighter a bit more
concise better ending trying to develop
sam's character it's tricky he's got to
be
needing help
but he can't be too desperate
he's got to be badass and likeable but
he needs to be somewhat demanding of hq
also so it's it's tricky balance that
we're going to try to find
what's the fastest way to kill somebody
with the soda can let's go quick stick
it in their mouth shake them up
what
what
what
oh yeah
dude you knock some mortar out of the
bricks
stop knocking that border out you crazy
man stop being crazy
[Music]
rocky this is the plan
rocky just the plan
that's great that's great i got it i got
it cool you got the intro anyways right
yeah and uh i mean
it's cool shaking and stuff because
i'm out
cool
how about the grenade explosion how do
you do that having grenade bursts that
was us with our air can shooting out a
bunch of flour and like wood chips and
stuff like that and dust
and then basically we just composited a
little like flare fire element on top of
that
and boom you have a grenade explosion
it always looks more real when you have
that little practical element in there
to
sell the effect so i hope you guys liked
the video and learned something from it
nico
hey guys listen up let me
know
hey top secret info check this out we're
gonna be hosting a huge 300 player
minecraft pvp battle so if you guys want
to play it uh follow us on twitter and
like us on facebook and we'll send out
all the info there the links are in the
description below
pay that landing
[Music]